だから下へ行く道 いわゆる堕落の道っていう意味なんですね
ブッダ・ゴータマはアヤっていうのはこのなんか禅
禅 ハピネスという訳もやってますけど
まあパーリ語を通してみるとそんな意味はないんです
ですから この人間の次元から考えると
人間のレベルより下へ堕落する
している 人間より低いレベルの生命に対してアパーヤと呼ぶんです
だから仏教では平気で動物の世界はアパーヤと言うんです
地獄は知りませんと言ったっても
アパーヤの一般的な意味は地獄って意味なんです
一般的なパーリ語でアパーヤという言葉使ったら
それ地獄なんです と言いながら
仏教でこの動物の次元も地獄だと言うんです
動物は人間の世界にいるんじゃないんです
地獄にいるんです どういうことですかというと
人間の次元から見れば
下のレベルにいるんですね
だからどう見てもあの動物にはいろんなところで自由はないんですね
自分が生まれて生まれると自分の体に刷り込まれる生命のプログラムパターンあるでしょうに
そのパターンプログラムによって生きて死んでいく
それ以上何もできない
だからどう頑張っても成長することは不可能なんですね
まあ猿は猿なりに決まってるパターンがあるし
でも猿は一度でも じゃあちょっと幼稚園ぐらいの学校でも作ってみようっていうことはしないんですね
で それと進化論はどうか関係あるかどうか
ちょっと言いにくいんだけどね
わからないんですけどね
本当に進化したかどうかということも
やっぱりいまだにわからないことなんですね
似ているんだからね 頭で思考で繋げたことでもある可能性あるし
まあ進化論自体は問題だらけなんです
だからといって神が作ったっていうことでもないんですけどね
それだったらもっとひどい問題が出てくるんだけどね
そういうのはあまりにもね
まあ昔話だからね 人間わからないだけで
じゃあ一応地獄という次元があるんだと
地獄という次元というのは人間の次元より低いレベルということで
どんな面で低いかというと
一番わかりやすいというのは
楽ですか？楽しみですか？その楽しみが低いと
苦しみが人間より多いと
それから善行為をいいことをしようとかね
立派になろうということはできない
自分が生まれたシステムの中に嵌め込まれてあって
そのレベルを飛び出すことはもう不可能です
ですから 大変かわいそうな
残酷な状態だと 人間にとってはいろんな可能性がたくさんあるんですね
人間にも乗り越えられないいろいろなものありますけど
やっぱりそれでもいろんな可能性あるんですね
で 一つ例で言うならば
人間も生まれたらもう寿命は決まってるんですね
どんな年で死ぬかと でも人間にいろんな工夫して
いろんな科学的なことを発展
発見して 発見して 寿命を延ばすということは不可能ではありません
100年じゃなくて 200年まで生きようとかね
300年までになりましょうとか
まあ今はできませんだけど
それから科学はどう発展するかもわからないし
もしそういうことを考えてしまったら
可能なことは可能なんですね
例えば体に早く壊れる部分はもう何でしょうかと
よく見て そういうものは長生きできるようにいろいろ工夫するとか
いくらでもできることはできるんです
病気とかね そういう人間に体に恐ろしいと思っている細菌は全部まあ何とかするとか
まあ今は抹消しようと思いますけど
それでは人間の病気は治りませんだけど
まあ私の方で言うならば
体に抵抗力作ってあげれば
どんな微生物が出ても
もう抵抗力あるような体のＤＮＡのプロセスをね
改善 改良してすれば どんな病気にも打ち勝つことはできるし
今の医学の教育プロセスではできないんです
いわゆるウイルスを殺そうと
ウイルスを殺しちゃうと
こっちが弱くなっちゃうんです
抵抗ないんだから だから地球から全部病気を消そうと思っちゃったら
同時にあなた方も死ぬっていうことになっちゃうんです
仏教的に言えば そうじゃなくて
もし地球上から人類からすべての病気を消したいんだというならば
体に抵抗力できるような
まあ遺伝 何て言いますか
そういう研究した方がいいんです
一応今植物にはやってるみたいですからね
まあそれは余計な話なんですけど
人間にはそういう可能性はあるんです
でも アパーヤにいる人々にはそれができない
我々知ってるアパーヤは地獄は畜生だから
動物の世界だから その動物にはそれは不可能なんです
怪我したらもう歩けなかったら餌取れなかったらそのまま座り込んで死ぬしか道がないんです
で たとえでっかいゾウであろうが
虫歯なんか出たら死ぬんです
どうしようもないんです
もう噛めないんです 痛くて
そしたらまあ まあそれで人間見るとね
やっぱりかわいそうやと思って
いろいろあのくちばしを折っちゃったら
何か人工的にくちばしを作ってあげたりとかしますけどね
それでまた餌を食べたりとかと
鳥はしますけどね それは人間がやるんであって
動物がやってるわけじゃないんです
スリランカでもゾウさんの歯の治療とかはやってあげるんです
で だからといってね 歯がきつく虫歯になっちゃったら抜くわけにいきませんよ
あれ抜く 機械でもって
それだってもう難しいし
それを抜いたって また動物やっぱり硬いものをね
噛んで食べなければゾウはね
噛んで食べなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから一応口を開けて
開けてみて あちこちなんかちょっとでも虫歯のようなものがあったら
そのサッサと治療してあげるんです
まあ虎とかみんなそうなんです
歯が一つでも抜けちゃったら
もうそれで死ぬしか道がないんですね
いかにかわいそうかというかね
その動物はどれほどショックを受けるでしょう
それからもう獲物取れないでしょう
牙四つあるでしょ それ一本二本ぐらい落ちるか壊れるかといったら
自分で知ってるんでしょうし
だからこの動物なんか死に覚悟をしてね
座り込んじゃってすごい悲しそうな顔になるんだよ
なんとか手当てできる場合もあるんだけど
ほとんどの場合はどうにもどうすることもできない
ですから やっぱり人間の立場から見れば大変苦しい次元だと
動物はそう思ってないんです
それはもう私的には 関係あることじゃないんです
それも仏教の世界でよく認めていることで
で アパーエと言うんです
で アパーエはもう動物の世界だけじゃなくて
この餓鬼道という言葉みんな聞いてるし
それからあしゅらですか
あしゅらってなんかややこしい次元なんですけど
これがもうわからないんですね
もしかするとヒンドゥー教から入った概念かもしれませんし
ヒンドゥーの文献ではもうあしゅらの話は結構あるんです
あしゅらっていうのは
修羅の反対の 神いて神の反対の言葉なんですね
だから神に修羅と言うんです
修羅というのは神という意味なんです
あしゅらっていうのは
その仏教でも地獄の一一つなんですね
だから日本語訳もできない
修羅という言葉は神と翻訳しちゃったら
あしゅらはどんな翻訳でいいんでしょうかね
英語でも直訳できないんだから
いろいろ工夫していろんな訳をするんです
で 餓鬼道っていうのはまた霊の霊界なんですね
現代日本語で言うならば
霊界という意味なんですね
餓鬼道のサンスクリット語
パーリ語はペータなんですね
これはヴェーダ語ではサンスクリット語ではプレータという言葉で出ているんです
それはピートゥスという言葉から出ているんだそうです
これはサンスクリット語だから
こちら母音ないんです
ピッツと発音するんです
このアの下に点を入れると
それも母音なんです 日本語
日本人は発音できないから
ルという風な発音で だからピッツスなんです
で このピッツというのは大変有名な言葉で
これは世界でどこでも使っている言葉なんです
ピッツというのは英語でファーザーという言葉を聞いたことがあるでしょ？ラテン語だとファーチャとかね
ドイツ語でもファーザーとか言うし
父という意味なんです
ですから これはヴェーダ語だから
古代同じ言葉 このインドアーリア言語でどこでも使っているんです
例えば母親父親というという言葉っていうのは
スリランカ語でもインド語でも英語でもドイツ語でもフランス語でも
すべてのインドアーリア系では同じ言葉なんです
手 耳 鼻とか そういう一番初めてできた言葉っていうのはほとんど同じなんです
で 目はパーリ語でサンスクリット語でアッキー
アクシーとかね 英語だったらアイでしょ
英語は新しい言葉なんですけど
ラテン語とかね あるいはアルトハクドイツとかね
そういう古いドイツ語とか見ると
もう似ていると 手はハスタというんです
で ハンドになってるんです
まあそれはそれでどうでもいいことで
あのピートゥという言葉が昔あって
戦争という意味なんですね
父親だけではなくて戦争を意味するんです
そこで そこで人が死んでいく世界という言葉が出てきたんですね
死んでいった人々には何かしてあげなくちゃじゃないか
そこでヴェーダ聖典ではこの儀式をやって
ヤーガをやって 護摩を焚いて
護摩っていうのは日本語の言葉ですけど
法螺ですね サンスクリットで法螺をして
この父たちに先祖たちに供養すると
で なぜ供養するかというと
死んだ人々は苦しんでいるんだと
食べ物がなくて いるところがなくて
着るものがなくて苦しんでいるんだと
ですから 必ずしも息子がその儀式をやらなくちゃいけない
ですから 遠い昔のインドでは
とにかく息子を作っておかないと大変なことになると
それを怖がっていたんです
で そういう習慣はまあ未だにあることは確かにあるんですね
家の責任 両親の責任は息子が持つべきですよと
でもやっぱり娘さんが見た方が両親にとってすごい居心地がいいんだけどと
で 娘にもそんなトラブルはないし
で 結婚する相手もね まあ自分のお坊さんの親戚だったら全然もう何の違和感もないし
で まあ残酷ですけど あの
まあとにかくそうなってるんですね
社会では 昔 この紀元前三年前の世界でもそういう風にあったんです
息子が供養しなくちゃいけない
その概念がどんどんお釈迦様は紀元前 6世紀だからね
まあお釈迦様より随分もう遠い昔の考え方なんです
あって どんどんその考え方が発展して
World Fathers ピートゥの世界
ピートゥローカという概念が出てきている感じです
いわゆる先祖たちの世界
ご先祖様の世界という世界の概念が現れてきている
そこにみんな亡くなる人はそこに行くんだと
そこを巡る人々には一番最初にあったのは
もう適当に毎月やら年に一回やら
あるいは毎日とか 決まってる仕来り
法話をやって供養しなくちゃいけないと
それを忘れちゃったら向こうは大変なことになるんだと
そこであるヴェーダ聖典であるところにこうあるんですね
もしこちらにいる人々が供養しなかったら
ピートたちが死んじゃうんだと
先祖たちが まあ特に人間では死んでるんだけど
あの世で死んじゃうんだと
あの世でも死んじゃったら消えちゃいますから
それを再現殺したことになっちゃいますから
それはかわいそうです
ですから 一生懸命法話をやるようにしたんですけど
その概念はあんまり発展しなかったんです
我々この仏教の人々はヴェーダ
ヴェーダ ヒンドゥー教を勉強すると
そういうところはわざと探しちゃうんです
ヒンドゥーの世界 そういうのは全然研究もしないんです
一番かっこいいところだけ取ってやってますけど
仏教の人々はそういうかっこ悪いところだけ探して
で 宗教歴史作っちゃうんです
まあどちらにでも証拠はあることは証拠はあるんですけどね
別に大したことないんだけど
まあ学者たちの遊びだから
で そこでどう考えたんですかというと
このピートの世界にいる人々にもちゃんと正しく供養すると
そこから昇格して天に行くんだと
ディッギヤになるんだとという言葉出てきて
もし正しく法務をやらなかったら
そちらから落下して苦しみの方に落ちちゃうんだという
また地獄という概念が出てきたんです
地獄と天国というのは
あのヴェーダ聖典とこのブラフマナという聖典
そういうのは読むと その思考の発展の道っていうのはすごく綺麗に見えるんです
人間はじわじわと新しい新しい概念を作って作っていっちゃうんですね
新しい概念を勝手に作るというのは
インドというのはものすごい
広い世界だから いろんな人々の考え方
システムに入って新しい概念になっていく
今のヒンドゥー教とはもう全然違うんですね
今のヒンドゥー教は本当にものすごい大きいすぎなんです
大きいすぎし あまり原始原始的すぎなんですね
昔あったすごい高度なお釈迦様の時代ぐらいでもあったの
高度なこの道はもう全くないんです
だからこの今 インドの選挙で勝った党ですか
このヒンドゥー教党ですか
そいつらあの人々がしゃべること聞くことに
本当にもう怖くなるほど気持ち悪いんです
それでもだから外国やらいろんな政治家がもうこの政府は大変危ないんだと
早くこの政府倒れなきゃ
もうインドはどうなるかわからない
それまであのいろんな激しい批判
世界中から出ているんです
だから まあ英語の新聞だったら
日本語でももう激しく批判があったんです
それは日本の記者書いたものではなくて
外国の誰かが書いたもの
で それでもその後は一応今政治政権を取りましたけど
で 一番最初に行って挨拶に行ったのはスリランカの大臣
で なんていうことかと
大体スリランカそんなこと関係ないと思ってるかもしれませんし
とにかくインドの機嫌を取っておいた方が自分の国の問題に対して
いいと思ってるし まあスリランカ人にとってはインドは誰が勝ってもいいんじゃないかっていう感じがありますけどね
まあ随分仲良くしているんだからね
建前だけは でもいいこともあるんだよ
今のある大臣がこのスリランカのテロ時にすごい炎上していたんです
それは他の人がそればらしちゃってね
この人にまあ大臣にふさわしいかと
スリランカにいろいろ問題作ってるんではないかと
やってはいけないことをやってるんではないかと
だからはっきり辞任するかはっきり決めなさいとか何とかも言ってるんだから
そういうところは我々の国にとってはまあタシになっちゃう
ですから 総理大臣の機嫌を取っておいた方がいいなと考えていたかもしれません
とにかくインターネット見たら
そのなんか自慢していたんですよね
一番最初に行って総理に挨拶したのは外国の政治家としてはスリランカでした
で とにかく現代ヒンドゥー教っていうのは
まあそんなにすごい立派なレベルではないんだけど
まあで だからといってインド教にはね
まあすごいすごい哲学的な時代とかね
ものすごい宗教も精神的な時期とかね
それはもう確かにありましたし
お釈迦様の後なんですね
すごく光り輝いたのは
ものすごいみんなもみんなそうしなくちゃと
ブッダに散々やられましたからね
すごく発展してウパニシャッド発展したのはそのあとなんです
だからお釈迦様出現後ウパニシャッドも少ないんですね
ということは当時でなかったっていうことなんです
で だからインドの場合は
宗教はいかに発展していたかという
この歴史はすごく綺麗に見えるんです
そこでこのピトゥの概念の発展が言ってますけど
そこで人が死ぬ それでいる人が悲しくなる
死んだことを認めたくない
ですから やっぱりピトゥの世界に行ったと
父の世界に行ったと 父っていうのは先祖っていう意味で使ってる
戦争の世界に行った じゃあ何かしてあげましょうという
まあ普通の人間の気持ちでしょうし
そこで幸福にいるんだというのを自分がそれで納得いくんだよね
で どんどんその考え方が発展しちゃうと
時代経つと宗教になっちゃうでしょ
ピトゥの世界はどういう世界かとみんながまた考えちゃう
それで供養しなかったらどうなるんですか？とか
供養しなかったら栄養がなくて死ぬだろうとかね
死んじゃったらそれで終わりでしょうと
それでもう壊滅するんだという概念が出ちゃったんだけど
それはまずいんだと その考え方発展しちゃったら
ということで壊滅するんじゃなくて
地獄のしちゃうんだと
それ息子のせいだと 地獄のしちゃった
ですから 息子たちは大変なんですね
必ずしも供養しなくちゃいけない
なんでそんなにも供養することはもう褒めてますかというと
供養するのはバラモン人なんですね
バラモン人にいっぱい財産あげなくちゃいけないんです
それで彼はそれで生きてるんです
仕事をしないんだから
バラモン人は ですから
とにかくヤーでやること
儀式やることこそすごい宗教だとあって
あれはお釈迦様時代で散々やられちゃったんで
あなた方は人のお金を望んでただ食べてるだけではないかと
人間はもう生まれつき聖者になれないんだと
心清らかな人がこそ聖者ですよと散々言われると
みんなああそうですか
じゃあ我々は心清らかにしようという風に瞑想の道がそれから発展したんですね
だから瞑想して善人になったのはバラモン人だけではないんです
どんな人でも瞑想して
もうもうなんとかそういうサマーディとか何とか体験があったらもう聖人で認めちゃうし
それでカースト制度はちょっと崩れちゃったんです
ですから インドの世界でもヨーガの場合はカースト制度はないんです
それはヨーガだけの世界で
誰にでも心を整えてそうして瞑想することできるんだから
でもそれはあんまり定着しないんですね
やっぱりまたカースト制度はまた顔出しちゃうし
今も顔を出してるし そういうふうなことです
で とにかくお釈迦様の時代になってくると
もうそのピートルという概念は確実にあったんですね
仏教になってどう変化しましたかというと
ある霊界がいて 死んだ人々が悪いことをしたならば
天国に行けるぐらいの徳がなかったならば
その霊界に落ちちゃうんだと
そこで苦しみ苦しんでいるんだと
自分やった行いによって
その霊界の一部が もしこの世の中の人々が
親戚が供養してあげれば
それなりに幸福になって
そこで死んで天国に行けるんだと言って
供養の概念もちゃんと守ってあげてるんですね
だから ある面で言えば
もう供養 そんなに意味がないかもしれませんだけど
また道徳の面で見れば
やっぱり生きている我々は
両親の先祖の並々ならぬ努力によって
この世の中でいるんだから
いきなり死んじゃったら
父はいないとかね 母なんかもう覚えてもないっていうのは
それすごい人間らしくないでしょうね
だから自分の母親父親亡くなって三十年経ってもありがたいと
よくやってくれましたという気持ちあった方が道徳的には素晴らしいことなんです
ですから 仏教はその徳があるんだから
供養っていうのは認めてるんです
否定しているわけじゃ何にも批判してないんです
供養するべきですよと
で それは息子だけですよと
それは言ってない それは親戚が供養するべきですよと
より広くするんですね
で 興味あるのは親戚ですから
同じ仏教の違う概念で考えちゃうと
生きている間は道徳は全く無視と
お寺なんか宗教なんか嘘くさいといた人が
もう死んでから じゃああっちお経あげてるんだから
じゃあ供養でもいただこうというふうに気持ちになるかと
だから僕らの文化から考えちゃうと
お坊さんが説法すると聞こうともしないで逃げる人が
あ 聞きたくなく面白くないと
それよりどっかに行って酒飲もうと
という人が死んでからお経をあげたりすると
説法したりすると来てありがたきじゃと聞くでしょうかと
というへりくつもすぐ出来上がりますけど
ですから まあそういうことで
いつでもお釈迦様が言うのは
自分の徳を自分で積んで
積んでね 自分のことを自分でやりなさいと
自分の将来のことを未来のことを自分で今手を打っておきなさいと
のことを自分でやりなさいと
自分の将来のことを未来のことを自で
今手を打っておきなさいと
それも言ってるんです
供養するのは生きてる我々の
まあいい行為であって
向こう側はそれを受けるか受け入れないかっていうのはまた別な話ですよ
私はできた娘でできた息子だから
父親は両親を大変大事に感謝するんだと
それは感謝の印としてお供する
両親ができでなかったならば
あの世で全然供養を受けてないというならば
それは決して息子娘のせいではないんですね
それはその本人のせいですから
その点で仏教は厳しい供養ですね
みんなこの息子の供養に頼って死んではいけません
でもお釈迦様は両親の希望のリストを書く場合は
両親の希望として いろいろ希望がありますけど
まあ家を守るでしょうとかね
財産をもっと大事にして
もっと増やして幸福になるだろうと
この息子は娘はとかね
それから 5番目に希望しているのは
私たちが死んじゃったら
まあなんとか供養してくれるだろうというぐらい
まあ希望としてあるんですけどね
まあだからといって じゃあ私は何もやらなくてもいいんだと
どうせ死んじゃったらこいつはやってくれるんだからと思っちゃったら
それは大違うです ですから仏教で言うんです
息子たちに娘たちに自分の親を大事にしたいならば
死んでから待ってはいけないんだと
死ぬ前に強引にでも徳を積むようにさせなさいと
その暇とお金あげなさいと
そうすると自分たちが自分でやるんだから
それでいいことになると
そういうことはあって
その餓鬼道と仏教で言っているのは
このペータの世界 パーリ語でペータと読むんです
ですから霊界であって
その霊界の中でも一部の住民たちが人間となんとか執着は捨てられなくて
人間の世界となんとかできるだけ何か関係を持とうと思っているんです
どうせ霊的な存在だから
人間にはわからない 見えませんし
感じませんし それでもその中に私たちのお父さん
お母さん 誰かが参り込んでいたならば
まあ供養すると受け入れるんですね
霊界はすごい大きいんです
ほんの一部だけ人間の供養を受けるみたい
そういう霊界は特別の名前で
また言ってる名前であります
で そのとにかくそれも地獄の一部なんですね
ペータっていうのは餓鬼道っていうのは
その餓鬼道の特色っていうのは
霊的な存在だから どうせ暗い心でそこに生まれちゃいますから
その次元は超えなくて
動物とほとんど同じなんですけど
何も成長できなくて そのままで苦しんでいなくちゃいけないということなんです
ただ 苦しみはほとんど精神的な苦しみなんですね
ですから苦しみが動物よりは多いんです
動物の苦しみっていうのは肉体的な苦しみなんです
霊界になっちゃうと体はそれほどないんです
体あるんだけど まあ人間に見えない体だから
で 心のエネルギーは強いんですね
ですから 心で悩むということは
強烈な悩みなんです 例えば痛いと感じるのは心で感じるので
ですから完全に痛み感じるんです
我々は痛み感じるのは体媒介して痛み感じるんだから
一部しか感じないんです
痛みの 怖さも我々は眼耳鼻舌身を通して怖いと感じるんだから
そんなに大胆な怖さじゃないんです
心直接怖さ感じたったらもうものすごい恐ろしいものなんです
ですからこの霊界は大変苦しみは多い
で アシュラという次元次にあるんですけど
アシュラっていうのはどんな連中かな
わからないんだけど それもおそらくヒンドゥー教の考え方だと思いますけど
神々は幸福で仲良くすることで平和を喜んで生きているんだと
神々の反対側が野盗側がこの怒りで戦いで苦しみで憎しみ合うことで生きているんだと
ですから あまり幸福な次元ではないんです
で 餓鬼道よりはレベル高いんですが
結局戦うこと 怒りを持つこと
あのいたずらすることやらね
とにかくもう相手を痛める
自分も痛めると痛みを感じる
それで刺激を受けて生きているんだと
そういう次元があるんだと
次にあるのは地獄というものなんですね
それはニロヤと言うんです
ペータとニロヤ  [背景音]ニラヤっていうのはこの
それはもう英語で言うヘルですか
まああれは地獄ということなんですね
で ニっていうのは全くないと
アヤっていうのは善だと幸福だと
またブッダゴーサ長老が訳しているんだからね
楽しみっていうのは全くない
苦しみのみ 苦しみしかない世界です
そこを苦しみしかない世界わからないでしょ？そういうふうに言ったら
それでいっぱいストーリーがあるんです
地獄に行ったら まあ舌は抜かれるわ
火で焼かれる ね まあ溶岩の釜があって
その中に入れて茹でるわとかね
鋸で切るわとか まあそれは地獄だよと
まあ言ったら いくらかね
昔の人々は理解するだろうと思います
今まで全くその通りだと思っている人々もいますけどね
で 私が考えたのは この大きな釜に入れてもう茹でちゃったら
それで死んじゃうと それで終わりでしょうと
でもそこで言うんです
そんな茹でたら死にませんと
で そこで地獄の鬼たちがお前お腹が空いたかと聞くんだそうですね
お腹が空いたと言ったら
大きな鉄の玉をね 真っ赤に温めて持ってくる
じゃあこれ食べなさいと言ったら
食べられませんだから怖くて口を閉めるんだと
そしたらお前今お腹が空いたと言っただろう
食いなさいと言って いろんなこの燃えている鉄の道具を持って口を開けて口の中に強引に入れちゃうんだと
入れたら全部燃やしちゃって
全部ボーンと下から鉄の玉そのまんまで落ちるんだと
落ちて死ぬかというと
そう死なないんだ それでその瞬間でまた体が元に戻るんだと
で また同じことを繰り返しちゃうとか
そういうふうに それはすごいわかりやすいストーリーなんですね
僕もほんのわずかしか言わなくて
そんなもんじゃないんです
もうストーリー聞くと
もうものすごい怖くなるほど恐ろしさですか
書いてるんです それは結局全部人間が考え出した苦しみなんです
人間にとってそんなことを想像すると
すごいゾッとするぐらいもう怖いんですね
で まあ百八 大きな地獄八つあり
八つあって 周りは四つあって
その周りまた十六分あって
一つの地獄の周りに百八地獄があって
かなり数あるみたい そこで一番苦しみが少ない地獄に行ったら
それはプーティグなんとかニレと言うんですね
この このすごい臭いところで
この まあ何と言いますか
プーティっていうのは
この人のあの便なんかあるところで
まあ固まって集まってるところみたいな感じで
で そこに生きているんだと
そこで虫たちが来て 皮から全部骨まで食べるんだと
骨まで食べて死ぬかというと
そう死なないでまた体が伸びてくるんだと
そういうふうなことを書いて
それは人間の次元で考えちゃうと
人がそういう汚いところに落ちて落ちて虫に食べられるんだと思ったら
それはちょっと想像 しにくいほど気持ち悪いんですね
それも地獄の一番この一番柔らかいランクなんです
本物の地獄ではないんです
それもこの本物の地獄で罪を終わった人々はどんどんどんどんどんどん昇格して
そういうところに行って
やがていいところに行けるかっていうことなんですね
ですから その地獄の苦しみを人間の次元で考えているんです
ですから お釈迦様は地獄はどんなものかと
あん坊さんたち 誰か聞くんですね
しっこく聞くと あんた方には考えられないんだと
ただ苦しいんだと 間違ってでも行くべきところじゃないんだと
言っても それでもお釈迦様は言葉をお上手ですから
たとえででも言ってもらったらどうですかと
言ったら このいっぱい
そのなんか台風とかね
あって 木はいっぱい倒れてあったんですね
じゃあそれ全部揃ってください
1か所に 全部この生きたまんまの木なん倒れて
まあですから 何て言いますか
捨てるものではないんです
ものすごい大量に で 集めてもらったんだと
そしたら お釈迦様は自分の超能力で
目に見えぬほど小さな火の玉一つ
地獄のところから上に上がってもらったと
やはり地球の中からちゃんと出てきたんだと
上に出てきた瞬間にあれはパッと火がついてもう燃えてしまったと
みんな驚いたんですね
あんなに強烈なほんの小さな火の玉に
これぐらい強烈な力があるんだと
驚いた 何のことない そんなことは地獄の苦しみに比べられないんです
1億分の何億分にも比べられないんだと言って
お釈迦様はそこたち出て行ったとという話があるんです
で もしかするとお釈迦様は地球の中にあるこの溶岩
ほんのちょっと出したならば
それでも我々も目で見えている
私もテレビで見ていたんだけどね
あの三原山ですか そこら辺で溶岩のほんのわずか
この学校の屋根に触れたんですね
触れた瞬間にパッと爆発したような感じで
学校がもう燃えてしまっちゃったんです
ですからすごいなと思ったんだけどね
この熱の強烈さっていうのは
で ですから 人間の次元では地獄という苦しみは感じられないかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様はそういう地獄っていうのはあるということは何のことなく認めているんです
苦しみだけの次元もあるんだと
ですから 私たち考えるようなものではない
この仏教のストーリーで出てくるようなものではない
それはちょっとした話であって
そんなものじゃないの
ものすごい強力な苦しみなんです
火に燃えると言った途端
人間が怖くなっちゃうんですね
だから聖書で出てくる地獄も永遠な火に焼かれているんだとというふうな火に例えていますけどね
で かなり強力な苦しみを味わう
だから我々と同じ体あるわけじゃないし
必要ないでしょう 例えば口を開けて火の玉をね
飲ませると だから何のために口があるんですかとね
聞く必要あるし それは人間の次元で考えるんだからなんです
だから いらないものは生命に出てこないんだから
食べないんだったら口いらないでしょうし
アメーバにしたって口がないんだから
アメーバは食べ物は体の中に入れちゃえばそれでいいんですから
体のどんな部分からでも入れればいいんです
だから口がないと体中口ですよと
だからこの生命はどのように栄養を取っているかということによって
体の構成は変わるし それで神々の絵なんかは絵画とか描いてるでしょうね
人間が あれ人間考えてる神であって
神はそんな形じゃないんです
なんで人間描く神はすごい綺麗な顔
綺麗な目 綺麗な鼻 綺麗な体とか全部ついてるんですね
あれは人間頭で思い浮かぶ
思い出せるぐらいの美しさを表現するだけであって
神に足があるんだったら
神々は歩かなくちゃいけない
口があるんだったらご飯食べなくちゃいけないし
そうでないと何のために口があるんですかと
それ聞きたくなりますけど
それ口があるんだ それぞれ消化器官なければいけませんし
ですから そこら辺もそこまでは考えないんですね
ですから 人間いろいろ瞑想して神に接近しようと思ったって
まだ頭に浮かんでいるあの概念があるんだからできないんです
心いくらか成長しちゃうと
なんとかコンタクトを取ることできません
できるんだけど ほとんど誰にもできないのはそういうこの概念ですね
概念が邪魔するんです
ということは 例えば実際に神がある神が来て
自分の目の前で見えるような姿にしても
人間はそれ神ですとわからないんです
人間に見えるための人間の頭で描いている絵描きさんが描いてる
あの通りに現れなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうわけで このいろいろ超能力者いうことは
まあ聞く 聞く瞬間にああ
なるほどと 僕は笑っちゃいますけど
今 義母さんが消えたんですかね
[笑い]